olá a todos sua alta aqui quem fala é o
dar que sejam muito bem vindos é mais um
vídeo e os tragos de que um ano e night
at fantin se eu acho que assim é e com
três tiros enquanto estava em busca de
jogos novos pelo game souto encontrei
que mais um fã do game do fight night
fredes realmente o que está na origem é
muito fã de games e por sinal bons funny
games porque pelo que ouvi sobre este
jogo está brutal porque foi tentar túnel
imagine um fight night at freddy's
contas na gente mas foi em cartum tipo
como é possivel cartunista estar é isso
que vamos ver por lá então só voltou a
aumentar o volume e segue agora jogar
aqui este ano no haiti é de flandes acho
que serei só quem sobrevive seis horas
que cá estou eu pessoal esta foi a
primeira imagem que houve neste jogo é
aparentemente está igual ao final de
sete sedes mas em cartum
ok temos aqui o nosso primeiro rei fred
improvisado que é tipo o zé cara
quadrada agora
ok temos usei o wo temos 100 óleo que
está dentro de um buraco
ok temos josé usei câmera espera você
quebra de pegada e meu pai que eu ia
mandar apoia ok o tio pior pesadelo
a resposta de estar meus não é suposto
estar marcando lá o seu pior pesadelo
qosi fora desta festa
não sei segundo marc bouwer extingo
placas maquetes meu isto parece um ser
tipo um jogo fácil na série friends
misturado com jogo em flash tá aqui
dentro da faixa a faixa
aquilo era que o zé manel estava ali à
frente na câmara quatro se não me engano
mas desta vez estava com os dentes [ __ ]
o que resolve por seu alô é um castor já
não tá lá no jornal por sinal é e não
pelo jornal o que quer dizer que vai ser
dessa ninguém mais se aproximou mais o
ovo turma aí é
tá tudo bem comigo também estarão os
momentos do jogo
o anda o funk é o que proporciona efeito
nem sei o que é possível na frente tanto
bartumeu ataque usando a cara quadrada
fuga
será que eu consigo cantar aqui alguma
coisa eu não percebi se isto é
interativo não por isso vou experimentar
tocar em algumas coisas daqui um mapa do
mar e o meu aqui o mapa
o cerro
alguma coisa vai saltar deste buraco né
falou alguém olha este assim eu estava
aqui jaz encheu a 11 o ovo fecha a porta
fecha a porta não apague as luzes vamos
continuar fechados lá o que ela câmera
câmera está sendo apagada meu calma
calma ela está aqui e não quero voltar a
salvar meu tio zé castro já não tá lá no
jornal é mau sinal é mau sinal vem aí eu
fui vai faltar por isso eu já saí lá
fumar um charuto cheiro não é isso aí a
música está a música foi à porta há
muita bateria não ainda tem muito e tem
muita uma da manhã pessoal vamos ter
conseguido sobreviver até às seis já
possa abrir as portas à nossa senhora
aí o bruno está a voltar outra vez na
questão o pataky tocar a música estava
lento com a música
o pai eu vou pra que eu vou comprar
aquilo que quer dizer que daqui a 10 ou
não não é causa e buffo josé do ovo
a mãe está tudo tranqüilo
está tudo tranqüilo o mesmo burrada
porque está em quarto mas assusta a
mesma
ok ok não sai daquela câmara meu lá onde
eu estou agora eu estou por ser um sonho
aqui né só fecha fecha aqui também só
pelo sim pelo não vêem aqui aí eu saí de
lá maria laura portas e nada que sai
nada que também já se foi embora duas da
manhã
eu acho que o máximo que nós aguentamos
até agora se bem que esta também é a
segunda tentativa faixa que alguma coisa
não zé do ovo é do ovo onde foi parar o
ataque josé do ouro foi para a câmera 2
o que significa que ela está muito perto
e por isso tentamos detectar atende que
10 ovo é que usei na cara quadrada
também não sei não posso dar-lhe prazo
lê sê da casa encontrava tão anda perto
e holanda perto pérola que ela tá aqui
câmara 40 a cara quadrada e câmera 5 já
não tá usando um ovo pois pois já sabia
da nova que mais outra vez lá
mario ajuda-la mario embora a cair
temos que ir pra e 60% bateria eu acho
duas da manhã já está a começar a
complicar pessoal duas da manhã e 60%
pátria meu curta que a do ovo outra vez
lá eu posso tocar essas músicas em cima
não acho que não foi embora
oita que o outro não chega para tudo my
nightmare e welcome
pessoal vamos tentar outra vez eu
consegui chegar até às duas da manhã eu
pelo menos quero chegar até às 3 só vou
ficar contente se com oscar atentado da
noite itha quilos é óbvio era cara
quadrada junte o que elas fazem juntos
cheguei meu vou ter que controlar estes
dois e os gestores também né
ox da questão do ovo está perto está
perto
não meu nome é jorge cinza do um sim por
favor me falar eu te amo
ana meu cérebro ao jato e um jato
preparar posso estar agora é um deus faz
falta em cima do zagueiro o cara
quadrada andar eu novo eu do ovo renda
do governo
ainda falta em cima de mim não eu não
querem saltar em cima pelo menos já não
é
eu já sei você iraque da sala é vou
enfrentar uma câmera e eles vão aparecer
é isso né agora olha agora lá não tá lá
falar que não fico aqui está ela tava
lusa o conjunto é meu
o zé o filme parece uma câmera porque o
pescoço eu não achei nada eu nem sei
nada não tinha nada eu juro que o juro
juro
juro que não tinha nada pra ganância do
juro na china a ficar tenso meu staff
cadência mil carregado isso meu caro
encontrando ficar tranqüilo é possuir
amigos posso senhora era realmente a
gente na câmera ok tá que o z na cara
quadrada e 10 rotativos é o pronto tudo
cansado
cansado ele usando um véu finaliza cara
tá aonde os ataques baixos atacar baggio
sabia dos da manhã eu caí às duas da
manhã é sempre condenou o ataque com
mais freqüência e por isso agora vamos
com os dois não é só um ou os dois
os dois e os dois está senhor falou
ainda que foi embora já usa a imagem
árabe pronto é maneiro ficar aqui muito
tempo eu pulei esta noite ao pé de mim
um pouco já sabia
eu já me assunto vem pois vazou e depois
vem outra vez já não percebo eu não
precisava
já não sei nada é muita pressão para
cima de mim traz amanhã conseguir cuidar
das três da manhã
ok já ganhou joga junto ao seu primeiro
ganho não dá
meu deus meu deus onde encontrou aí o
descontrole de controlar e fechado a
porta eu vi tse que o equipos é fox e
imagens da castor neste jogo não vou
jogar mais disse pessoal e chutar
consegue ser pior do confaz noite feliz
mesmo sem nem cartune por isso é isso ao
modificar porque com isto a night at
funks se quiserem ver mais me digam que
não querem é se quiserem ver mais
comentem mas digam que não querem deixar
o vosso apoio aic favorito fique bem até
a próxima
ok
o